it turns out that yahoo was letting the
NSA read your email even before you
opened it Yahoo Inc last year secretly
built a custom software program to
search all of its customers incoming
email for specific information provided
by US intelligence officials the company
complied with a classified US government
demand and what they would do is scan
hundreds of millions of yahoo mail
accounts at the request of the National
Security Agency or FBI and this is all
according to three former employees and
a fourth person who knew about this
there are some surveillance experts who
are saying this is the first time that
we're seeing a u.s. internet company
agreeing to an intelligence agencies
request by searching all arriving
messages as opposed to examining stored
messages are scanning a small number of
accounts in real time let me translate
in layman's terms Yahoo was scanning the
messages and reporting to the NSA about
those messages before the recipients
even read them now it's not known
specifically what information
intelligence officials were looking for
only that they wanted yahoo to search
for a set of characters this could be a
phrase in an email some kind of a phrase
or wording in an attachment uh unclear
exactly what it means but this is sort
of the gist of it and Reuters was uh not
able to figure out what Yahoo may have
handed over so if we sort of imagine a
tiered system you've got all yahoo email
being scanned by these uh filters then
you have some specific words phrases or
signatures that were being looked for
and then you have some portion of that
and it could be a hundred percent of
that being turned over to authorities
now this it's it's known that US phone
and Internet companies are known to hand
over bulk customer data to intelligence
agencies but there are some former
government officials and private
surveillance experts who said they have
never seen or heard
of such broad real-time scanning
collection and reporting of customer
emails and data and as soon as this
happened as I sort of mentioned earlier
my interview with bruce schneier
Microsoft Twitter Google Facebook Apple
they all very quickly put out statements
saying oh we don't do anything like this
we haven't received requests like this
we haven't complied with requests like
this as Bruce Schneier mentioned in our
interview earlier in today's show he is
skeptical of that to say the least and
Apple specifically pointed to a recent
statement made by their te CEO Tim Cook
which said I want to be absolutely clear
that we have never worked with any
government agency from any country to
create a backdoor in any of our products
or services we have also never allowed
access to our servers and we never will
here's the way in which the wording is
so important this is what Bruce Schneier
was referring to if we look at this
statement from Apple now this is all
speculative I want to be clear if you
look at was it what he says he says we
have never worked with a government
agency to create a backdoor okay that
might mean they created the back door on
their own without working with a
government agency or that they worked
with the government agency to provide
data in a way that isn't through a back
door right this is why Bruce Schneier is
saying these denials need to be looked
at really closely and his last sentence
we have also never allowed access to our
servers and we never will well you can
very very easily mirror what is on your
servers or parts of it on to some other
shared server that Apple and the NSA
might have shared access to and you
would be right you have never allowed
the NSA access to your servers but it
doesn't really represent the spirit of
what it is Tim Cook is saying I'm not
saying this is what Apple was doing I I
merely want to have the conversation
with you about how these are worded in a
way where anything could really be going
on meanwhile Yahoo put out a statement
that doesn't deny that the program
exists they're not really denying any of
this it's a pretty but milquetoast and
generic statement and this is really
really concerning and it might be
interesting for you to know that
at one point Yahoo was fined for not
participating in prism which was another
one of these sort of surveillance
security type initiatives they were
fined for not participating at one point
in the past and now we learn they are
participating in a different way uh in a
way that exceeds even our wildest
expectations of what was going on so
very very concerning stuff from Yahoo